so let's stop worrying about
accessibility for a moment and get hyped
to the new souls game this is a quick
video about what's been confirmed with a
few predictions thrown in Dark Souls 2
will be a direct sequel to Dark Souls
and will feature a more content dense
world around the same size as Lord Ron
however the game will not take place in
Lord run even though we see places
resembling the painted world and Anna
Londo a number of sources have stated
that the main theme of the game is time
so perhaps we will see a phasing in and
out of time periods there's a main hero
in Dark Souls 2 and whether we play as a
set character is unknown at this point I
have a feeling the new main characters
Gwynn's firstborn who is exiled from
Lord run I say this because it just
seems to fit the game doesn't take place
in Lordran
and the son's firstborn is an important
character who exists outside of Lordran
the characters regal armor bears some
similarity to Gwynn's and the voice of
the start of the trailer almost sounds
like a father denouncing his son
this is just my theory though so don't
take it as fact when the game is set is
impossible to know but bear in mind that
the regardless of which ending you
choose in Dark Souls the flame will
always be fading
I assume this is still a theme in the
second game since on the Dark Souls 2
website and we see an image of the world
freezing over cold can be associated
with dark regardless of what the story
is it's a fact that the law will be less
subtle with Shibuya running the show
however there will still be hidden
elements to the story and that's a good
thing
with a more apparent storyline it's my
hope that Dark Souls 2 gets many more
people interested in searching at the
subtleties of the law it's a shame that
so many people missed out on the great
story of Dark Souls and a more obvious
storyline at the surface in Dark Souls 2
means more people will be interested in
seeking out the deeper parts of the law
at least that's what I hope will happen
hopefully I'll still be able to make
prepare to cry for Dark Souls 2 Dark
Souls 2 is going to look amazing
graphically considering the new console
generation should roll in at the end of
next year it's hard to say whether the
game will be released as a next-gen
title regardless it will be released on
PC and reach its full graphical
potential on that platform a petition
was made for a release on Wii U but I
doubt it will be heard by Namco Bandai
let's finish with a talk about the
gameplay bear in mind that every souls
trailer hints of what we're going to see
in terms of gameplay Dark Souls 2 of
masks and Dragons shows strong
characterization and depicts a journey
the main character is dual wielding
which I expect we'll see in game
especially since Shibuya talks of
enhancing the action there will also be
a system in the game where the player
can keep a track of the clues they have
uncovered sounds a bit like a journal or
a quest log which I hope that they can
implement properly the new directors
have expressed interest in the notion of
snow and weather which almost make it
sound like the game could have our
dynamic weather system imagine how the
mood of the game could be enhanced if
you were travelling through a forest and
it started raining or snowing speaking
of the mood Shibuya expresses excitement
about the ocean or the sea as a Khan
that hasn't been done before in Seoul's
games in Japan it's an iconic idea that
when you're standing by the sea alone
you're often depressed this fits the
souls games pretty well the world design
team at from software is huge and a
focusing of making unique environments
this time around it seems like we'll be
able to travel through these
environments at speed as the team wants
to implement vehicles the only two that
have been suggested so far are ships and
chariots which should suit the fantasy
theme in terms of new enemies we have a
grotesquely obese enemy wielding sickles
a dwarf with the monstrous acts a giant
spider parasite that takes over human
bodies a black rider who punishes the
player for evil deeds and a relatively
normal enemy that it was apparently
top-secret this blind bandaged zombie
with a gaping open ribcage was not open
for discussion with the new director
finally we will see a return to server
based PvP in Dark Souls 2 like we had in
Demon Souls this will mean a better
online experience that just about sums
up everything that we know so far and
hopefully it hopes you get hyped in
other YouTube videos comments
communities and articles I've noticed a
lot of pessimism about Dark Souls 2
which I understand however it's not a
bad thing if the game takes risks we see
so many other franchises being rehashed
and repackaged as the same game every
year and I don't want the souls series
to die like that the game is going to
change but I want to see the series
evolve and I want to see the developers
learn something new every time they make
a new game that's how you keep a series
fresh and alive and I'm sure the game
will be more than just accessible anyway
thanks for watching guys I hope you
enjoyed the video